Well my name is pain. And I'm here when I Miss
Benson and today if January twenty eighth two thousand and sixteen.
We advocate a
library for the after our stories project at Brooklyn public library films I never
before the my way from.
Yes I transferred to dos to in housing in the year two
thousand from Coney Island Houses. I found the neighborhood to be
all seemed quiet friendly but
that was fixing years ago. Things are different now.
Should I continue where you have more questions. Oh
well the element is on the
negative and it wasn't been.
Well when we first arrived what did
it was well as
I said it was very clean the area was quiet and the people
of extremely friendly. Now you know it's difficult to get a good morning
from your neighbors and that type of thing you
know part
of that because you know I joined I
retired so I've joined a couple
of. Programs that they have here in
a neighborhood. You know one is the. Base Senior Center which
is very nice you know you meet a lot of people and everything. So you know the lunches are
delicious for one
dollar or so
the the kings of a
Y. which is on
Avenue B.'s the
notion and it's it's very good as a beautiful pool
an exercise room.
I have exercise classes are all the classes and that type of thing people
are very nice there as well you know but the main thing that I
was really excited about is the Tenet
association with the father of McFadden He is
the
president and I learned about them through pulses
the memorandums and stuff that were placed in the buildings and stuff
and if you know she's she's really trying to bring
the neighborhood back to as when I first moved here. You know she's gotten
all sorts
of programs.
The recycling program which is good clean cleaning up the
neighborhood and I got a lot of alums.
That's
all you know than me one of the
nicest things that she have to win is a GED program which is partnered with
the Brooklyn College. So that's that's very nice.
She she had a youth
summit to Albany was she took a lot of the you see you know
and you know teaching them how life is and how to pay them for life
and you know a lot of different things you know her her motto
is you know taking back the community. You
know it was she she was really working hard you know she's the a breath of
hope here no light at the end of the
tunnel. You know type of person though you know with her. I think
I'm going to be the year two
thousand in August and once
again with a lot of children when you first arrive.
Yeah the way.
Well you know I think the change came about
because a lot of the seniors. You know these are the people that
were living here. For years and years and years when I moved
in there with a like a few of my
neighbors that way here like twenty years in
and. Longer than that thirty years and forty years of
them and a lot of them are dying out. You know. So as they die out
and stuff and then the apartments are being taken over by people that aren't
as caring. Still that's what a
change is coming about you know you just don't seem to you see
children just going to see children as young mothers I'm moving in. Now and that type of thing.
So
yes in my building we don't have very many young children but we
have a few.
Maybe about six families or something like that.
Here
who will live life in the community are the coming
and oh well Coney Island was fantastic.
I've moved into a new building that had just gone up.
This was in the seventy's and I moved in with
my young daughter at the time and then I had another daughter while I was
the but it was gorgeous. I
mean it was like the best place for me to raise my kids you
know I would work and their backyard was the beach and
the amusement park and the aquarium. You know and the parks were fabulous
then you know very nice soul. You know my family for
LARP and moved out as the so I didn't need a big apartment anymore it was
a duplex on top of that.
So it was very nice very
nice and if so I moved to Florida death but
maybe transfer over to
notion less rooms I didn't need as many in
the here. We
always born and raised I was born in Harlem Hospital. Yeah. So.
I don't remember very much about Harlem because we moved into
Brooklyn what green area was where I was raised.
And we moved
here when I was hanging when I was very young I don't even know
the age. But I was a school there and all of
that and. I'm losing my train of thought that
that's what you call a senior
moment. Anyway.
So
for Greenlee What do you remember about that era
disposed of for green it was great friends were
different back then you know I was born in. Fifty one
still times were different
then you know your friends in with sibilance you know and you ran
the streets with each other and we played games we actually played games as kids punchbowl
a ring a levy all and all of that or you went to your girlfriend's health
and ate and your mom fed them and there was it was great it was it was a
beautiful community.
And I'm still in touch with some of those people now you know because that's how I was
friends were friends you know and we know each other's children and all of
that so many years
later but I you know what King was very very nice when I've been
to public school and did you know high school there.
Has a lot of us stayed with me was.
P.S. sixty seven was the public
school and sand junior high school.
Yeah. I I went to say
a jail.
You know
that third or third Avenue no. Sin Brooklyn.
Vocational program. Yes yes yes yes yes I took the nursing. Program. Yeah
yeah so it was good
to win into the co-op program is that they had things like
that they had so many things back then to encourage young people
to go to school like there is a tomorrow is own like the.
Like the co-op program where you work a week or two to try to get was then and you go to
school for two weeks you have to be a good student for that of course to be able to keep up your
classes and then at the end you able to work with this from whatever
company to put you in what was is a
great incentive. Yes yes yes this yes.
They had so much and also the young children. Unlike unlike
now you know they they're not thinking about the youth.
They don't have very much
to occupied and my brothers went to the boys and girls high school
playing basketball and all these different things so they you know
all those programs have been cut out. Unfortunately I remember
him for green there was a.
A
A Catholic Church was in the name of the church all I
can remember the church right now because I'm under
pressure. As say Michael St
Edward's and
this priest used to have all sorts of programs to get us off the street you
know he would have nice movie nights you know what we would go we'd watch movies
and he would have basketball tournaments and all sorts of things you
know
just everyone seemed to just open your doors to the young people you know.
And unfortunately you know that's what they need when they finish with school they need another place to go.
I believe now. You know because the you know the
parents and
and I my my both my parents worked here and also. We will latch
key kids you know but these are but when you. You
know that it was took the neighborhood to raise one child you know when you
weren't really alone you know if you had anything you're going to explore to miss this value Mr
Weber whatever you know
so people have to now start
reaching out again
and sewing something I don't know what the change is
none of
the great about the change of the status
of the YES YES YES YES YES I'm loving it
because I'm able to to get into the different committees
that Barbara sets up. You know.
So it makes me feel good to know I'm doing some things you know.
What the for what they
do was lose it's a lesson in this area.
Even
a father
here sixty
well I really you know I could tell the I couldn't
really tell you much about the neighborhood because I worked. You know so I
basically went to work and I had my children. Well I don't have my child when
I moved here but I worked
in I worked twice town at Long Island College Hospital.
So by the time I got home I was just in my house and ready for the next day
type of thing.
But since since I've retired is true to Plaza they put up
the signs and stuff and they've beautified it a little you know but
I really don't know much about the neighborhood I'm more or less learning about it
now since I have the time to walk around and see what's available and what it's
in and that type that the so we speak with
the library.
Oh yes I come to. The library. I don't wanna speak negative of it
but that told me where you could speak of this library
because they they're very noisy you can't concentrate
on whatever it is you know when and in not only to the kids to comment
the staff as well the yelling
across a family Did you follow whatever you
know or
or you know they need to clean up the
the the restrooms a little better. You know it's it's really
bad so maybe they
need to hire a housekeeping person or whatever you
know
but the programs that they have point
really much for the kids you know it's like some board games that this is for little kids and
that type of thing but you know get something for the teenagers you know that they
can get more involved
with that's why you know they come here I
guess out of the cold and all
of that and you know they sit in a me play games or something that they
may bring in themselves to share or something like that you know so of course you know they're going to
be talking and what have you as I guess that's clear that noise comes in you got a cut on this
thing and
but you know when I come I like to be quiet sit and read my book and get into
the characters and all of
that you know
but it could be a bed a library if they if they
whoever runs it that
I care about it a little more about the neighborhood in one
of
that but it's the
the the shelves of plenty of books and you know it's
it's fairly clean it's just a rest rooms that
aren't and.
That's all the negative I have
this. Ball
to poor library.
And the libraries like it was a big thing in raising my kids we they
had to live used to have a lot of programs reading programs and all sorts of things because I
have my daughter is involved in all of that they don't have that here you know.
You know you read so many books and you get a free book in there was one of the program I did
so long
local one time memories coming back home.
But
life was different back then people cared about people and they were cared about kids
in you know nowadays you see a teenager come to the door ready you. You know want
to defense. You know and it should not be you know it doesn't matter what race
the child is
it's still the same reaction. You know and that a helping you
know the young. What do they know they don't know about how to approach or how to not
to approach to teach them so OK but when you come in and say such and such
will you remove your head only you know what I have to learn.
You know five and they you know you want to talk and.
When leaving.
I think something will give me a little it's
up.
So you said you're going to learn about me and he frequently. Why are you
hearing him. There is how
you know in your community that.
Before.
All those are the three centers that I do call to I
go down the block and I get fine nails and feet done and the people know me P.S.O. You
know I've you know we talk. It's
no Chetry in and why.
Yes and I go there I get buy nails and then sit and talk
with the ladies of
the. And then there's a deli.
Dyna right on the corner
of the and no Strand.
Every now and then I'll go in and the guys know media you know
when and it's nice to go there because they just all high and they bring me my stuff
sold you know I feel like a queen you know. So when I have visitors I bring them here.
So it's very very very clean very nice the food is good and
not expensive. You know over the expensive
pedal. Where else do I thought oh I like all to
Kings Plaza or of course and you know down the flat boyish
and I just wonder
why it's so good after working so many years to
just wake up and say What am I going to do
today where which direction am I going to
go. Yeah
but that's the tenant though she
says it's great because I have learned a lot of my neighbors.
You know and it's good that meetings
are very informative.
You
know
I don't know from the other things to say.
Something
that. Well basically I
just have a list of the programs that was started
by
association. One that you're particularly proud of that you work for.
One mission one.
Well you know during Christmas time. This big
fan and I stay at the
they got together a trip to a Christian Cultural
Center feces. Everyone knows that church mostly and it was green
it was a they had a Christmas show and at the end of the show the kids got
a
toy and a book you know and they you loved it it was great
you know so I was one of the chaperones on the bus.
You know but it
was it was very nice very nice I thought there was very sweet.
People were on the bus.
Well whatever the bus holes because it was full and everyone was
seated. But I don't know how many see that in
the Bible. It was very nice and the kids were
so well behaved as they are you
dolt as they always are
so that was nice and they all
live. In the area here in the area.
I know in the beginning when I first started coming to the.
Meetings they they had a nutrition
program and that was nice I learned a lot from that and
I think it was like one day added a week for like six weeks or something
like that and you learned a lot
about counting calories and reading
labels and things of that.
But I really got a lot out of that because I used to take the.
P.S.L. oil pills I forget black seed pills or something like
that and in the class. You know you'd learn that those polls tablets
they put like the worst oils you had oh it's not it's not quality.
So I said Oh what am I doing so I stopped taking that you know when you have to be careful
you know then I guess that's why they tell you to when you're taking these open account of
supplements you should you know speak to your physician because they can tell you.
More or less that this. What's good or what isn't good
or you know that type of
thing but. It was fun
it was very very informative.
That's what I like about our partnership make sure that you.
You know you're learning and you know she's she's a person that believes
in sharpening the mind you
know you know will
help her meetings and I
just you know they're all informative somehow you've been formed
about something you
know and she feeds you. Oh my
goodness she's all thoughtful because people are coming from work or whatever you know
and she always says of me only a four year you know sometimes.
Actually I don't know who the cooks but the food the usually very good chicken
and mac and cheese or not you know always a dessert.
And believable that lady is and she's coming from work or self.
You know so she makes plans all of
this. So I look forward to
our meetings.
With Suze very little.
But.
Well is there anything that you like to two generations to know
about King same even and
in
one's own area.
What to expect. Well.
I'm not a fortune teller so I don't know
but
but F. thinking so starting to progress as it
is maybe you
know things be better because I see the kids outside
now claims basketball and stuff like that which I didn't see
before you know so I guess maybe some young man decided to get some
kids together and get. Team together whatever it
is but I don't know I don't even
know how to answer that
one maybe one
moment Les's you may have learned.
Let me hear oh
yeah
well at sixty five this folly any less
incentive you're going to learn from a neighborhood that you haven't learned from any other you know you just
learn how
to you know we all live here together. You know. And no one
is better than the
other and we should just reach out our hands and I help one another the best we
can
and basically that's it you know you see some
huge remember you're growing up. You know the elders you
just reach out for the elders see if they need help here Knowledge children the
children understand that you know you were child once in and I get so upset
but little noise the whatever it is you
know or the
Basically that's it you know we're all here together.
You know you you may have a better job or you may not have a job but we're all in the same boat.
So you'd know better then than the next
person and that's a lesson for everyone to
know here.
Well thinking this isn't a high this is and sharing your memory.
This is one. OK. Thank you.